un clip de promotion et des témoignages
comme celui d'un sportif hervé arcade à
carhaix on constate ensuite que chaque
nation à 100 à son drapeau
la collectivité territoriale à hyères
lancer une consultation pour doter la
martinique d'un drapeau britannique
l'objectif pouvoir s'identifier dans les
compétitions internationales
une initiative appréciée à la ligue de
foot nous avons toujours expliqué que
lorsque nous arrivons en compétition
face à de grandes nations du football et
en particulier dans les phase
protocolaire vous avez les hymnes
nationaux qui sont joués vous avez
également les drapeaux qui sont face aux
équipes qui est qu'ils sont en
compétition
il y a parce qu'une forme de
tétanisation de nos joueurs lorsqu'ils
regardent
face à eux des équipes nationales c'est
vrai en train de chanter à tue-tête la
main sur le coeur l'hymne de lors de
l'euro de leur pays d'autres territoires
ont déjà fait la même démarche
la guyane par exemple aujourd'hui dans
l'opinion publique l'idée de
s'identifier aux côtés du drapeau
français ne choque plus survint un tour
avec le drapeau de la martinique tout le
monde reconnaîtra ce sont les atc la
martinique c'est nous je pense qu'on est
français donc il faut quand même
respecter cela et je suis pas tellement
pour
le drapeau martiniquais c'est mon avis
non je pense que si on a un hymne à
faire mais c'est la france qui a déjà
une histoire de drapeaux qui tourne déjà
au niveau de la martinique devrait pas
être connu dans le rouge et le vert
donc je pense que s'il ya peut-être
possibilité de garder ce cap aura
maintenant fait vraiment plus accentuée
sous l'hymne de lamartine
mais voilà justement où va se poser le
débat dans l'appel d'offres de la ctm
il est bien question d'un hymne et d'un
drapeau des créations uniques et il
précisé une disposition qui fait bondir
certains car elle pourrait d'emblée
exclure le drapeau rouge vert noir
je vais proposer le diable rouge et noir
qui et puis en plus à la peau et qui a
un excédent qui a passé et parce que
nous faut pas oublier que sur un drapeau
est né en prison à faux pas mais tant
qu'on vienne nous est posée quel que
soit le capot qui va même non pas du
tout je ne connais aucun pays où c'est
un concours d'artistes qui détermine une
qui détermine rendra fou quoi donc je
trouve que ce qui a un côté peut être
insultant par rapport aux militants tels
que alex sur dinan
cabon masson et puis tous les partis qui
ont adapté qui ont adopté ces couleurs
là donc il ya un combat qui a été mené à
des gens qui ont été en prison l'artiste
nicolas nelzy est membre d'un collectif
lyannaj rouge vert noir qui cette année
a multiplié les actions autour du
drapeau brandi dans les stades ou par
les artistes ce collectif qui
s'exprimera officiellement lundi
s'inquiète également des modalités
choisies par la ctm un seul mois de
consultations et un choix final fait par
un comité